pour l'instant ce n'est qu'un terrain
vague avec seulement quelques parpaings
poser dans quelques mois c'est ici à
trappes que ce bâtiment flambant neuf
sera inauguré un bâtiment dédié
entièrement au 281 associations de la
ville et qui doit alors profitez de
point d'appui pour l'ensemble de leurs
projets les associations peuvent se
retrouver préparer leur dossier préparé
leurs différentes actions
à voir sur place un ou deux partenaires
municipal agent municipal si vous voulez
qui est capable de donner des réponses
dans du riz 10 dons financiers suivre
l'organisation situé en plein coeur du
quartier de l'aérostat qui prévoit à
terme la construction de 800 logements
ce nouvel équipement public répond aux
besoins du tissu associatif local vie
culturelle sportive ou solidaire il doit
permettre également de pérenniser les
projets innovants et à des niveaux qui
vont s'opérer au niveau de la mda à la
fois stabiliser aider les associations
existantes et à la fois faire en sorte
que d'autres jeunes puisse émerger
parce que où dans le monde à cet effet
également assez du bénévolat il arrive à
un moment où les gens sont essoufflés il
va falloir remplacer il faut que ça
continue il faut que les associatifs
puisse continuer et servir comme bien
des tissus social au sein de la ville de
trappes la livraison du bâtiment est
prévue pour septembre 2018 coût de
l'opération un peu moins de 2 millions
d'euros